so this is a tech prediction that blends
into some of the other stuff we're
talking about I think that uh 2024 ends
up becoming the AI cycle where you have
uh deep fake videos uh and audios down
the stretch over the last several weeks
uh that uh end up causing a lot of
confusion and turmoil um you saw this by
the way there there was another country
where like there's a last minute deep
fake and it might have made the
difference think was Estonia so your so
you're going to see uh this be the AI
cycle all sorts of weird shit's going to
come up in our social media feeds over
the last uh two three weeks and that
could be one of the defining Elements by
the way it's also going to make it so
it's uh it's easier for folks to um
argue that there was fraud or uh
something uh was rigged or stolen
because that there's going to be a lot
of AI generated confusion down the
stretch of the Fall so here's what
the political tactic is so you can't do
deep fakes in a multi-state
primary too often because there is a
good and I'm happy for this there's a
healthy public backlash if you do it and
it's happened I think Des santis did one
where it's it's not good and you have to
apologize and you have to say that was
wrong or I don't agree with that right
but when you're talking about late in
the game stuff or like winner take all
so it's the end of super Tuesday or the
national
election what will happen is some Savvy
political operative or company will
create a deep fake video and run ads on
it on TV or wherever it is um or deep
fake phone calls Etc that have their
opponent doing something awful something
that you know and you have this data
like it crosses a line that voters
really really don't like right it's a
it's it's something like U showing that
a republican is pro-choice instead of
pro-life like last minute right
something awful or something personal
attacks Etc and it happens last minute
so you can't really respond it's right
before election day and then the
election happens and people either stay
home or vote a different way and then in
the aftermath you'll find out usually um
because it's going it has to go to
enough people for it to be public but
then the election happened right and so
that's what's GNA happen the question is
do people tune it out do they are we
used to this Etc but to your point it's
the first one it's the first time we're
doing this right so you have some you
have folks my mom's age and others that
are the demographic voters and they're
seeing something that looks and feels
very real what are they going to do I
don't know it doesn't look great and so
that I agree with you it's a powerful
political AI prediction my prediction on
AI is that we have an
AI it's my similar prediction I had web
3 and maybe I'll be wrong again but uh
AI gets Mass adopted in some version I
think it's going to be a personal
assistant I think that's the first one
where like what hey Siri is um where
Siri is where it's hey book me an
appointment write this email get me a
reso I think it gets really good there
um I could be wrong but that's no I I I
think that's a good prediction uh I just
met with an entrepreneur who's working
on an AI therapy bot um which by I think
there's a lot of potential for there's
some angles what's crazy Andrew is when
we were running you were talking about
um
non-repetitive cognitive work you're
like cognitive or repetitive and so
non-repetitive cognitive work was the
ones that we thought would be
quote unquote safe but now you're seeing
like design and musicians and AI really
kicking ass in some of those areas as
opposed
to it sucks at like it sucks at writing
somewhat uh it can do basic writing but
it's but like there's there's certain
Lanes where I thought creatives would
stay strong and like anything repetitive
would would get rocked and it's not as
clear-cut yeah yeah the the repetitive
non-repetitive stuff I mean so rep
comptitive you think it's rules-based
like accounting bookkeeping um the the
tough truth is that a lot of quote
unquote creative work also uh is kind of
repetitive and like follows rules you
just don't really you know uh uh know
them as clearly but AI can produce art
there AI logo gen generator that I've
used and it's objectively good and
here's the other thing it does like the
basic work it gives me a hundred
Concepts a thousand Concepts then I can
take that to mass it right it's the same
like I tell people it's great at naming
things where he name this thing and
they'll give you five 10 suggestions and
then you might not choose any of them
but you you're going to end up
springboarding off of one of the
suggestions uh to the one you want you
get an infinite brainstorm St you know
what I mean like think about when you're
trying to name something you like Google
synonyms Etc it just give me 20 names
for a healthc care policy whatever you
want to do right for a new company that
does X it's
first of all it's very exciting and very
frightening and everybody knows this um
and I think it's why I like listening to
you I still listening to your podcast
because
you you understand the sorry man I mean
that's hysterical sorry yeah I listen
yeah um I like I don't listen everything
it's tough sometimes but I I try to do
as many as can but you like the the
economy Humanity political tripod of how
AI is going to affect that's the type of
like ership we need and that's the type
of like foresight we need it's one
reason why I'm I'm actually grateful to
everyone who who tunes into the podcast
I was I just I was just at uh like an
industry event and apparently podcasts
have uh gotten shelled right in the left
and I was like oh shoot like we're
actually doing fine we're like growing
like uh you know so thank
you hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you